Thank you for the teachers' day wishes,
and...
Let me share.
So we have a few things pending from,
I've started the recording.
So we have a few things pending from the
previous session. That is,
I wanted to go from harness engineering
to context, then to prompt,
and then drag it.
That's how I wanted to go.
So we discussed good amount of time on
the harness part.
So context is something which we will not
get into detail because context window,
while talking about context window,
we had discussed the importance,
but only the engineering aspect is
something which we need to do.
And we have to understand the difference
between context prompt and how it is
leading to other types of engineering,
etc.
So that part I will finish and then today
I will get into the other parts of the
topics which needs to be covered is more
on the
context prompt plus the entire AI layers
plus the stack.
That's what I wanted to cover for today.
So once we finish that,
We have a few discussions.
I not starting with the module on.
requirements today.
I will start it in the next class. Okay.
And for the examination also,
I have decided that we will not have
whatever has been covering in the next
class because I want,
since you have only a week's time for the
exam.
For next class,
I thought it will be too much to cover
and then immediately ask you to prepare
that. So whatever we cover till today,
that is CS7.
Today is contact session number 7.
So whatever we cover till today, CS7,
that will be your.
portions or syllabus for the upcoming
mid-semester exam.
Whatever we cover in CS8,
we can ignore at this point of time.
We will take it up in the comprehensive
exam.
Okay,
this includes both regular and makeup.
Some of you might be opting for the
makeup exams.
So both for the regular and makeup exam,
this would be the...
Syllabus, whatever we covered till today.
OK,
and I will also talk about a few things
about the exam. I know many of you are.
I mean, almost all of you, I think,
are first semester.
So how do you want to approach the exams?
as part of this course is concerned. Okay.
We'll have,
we'll talk about that a few things.
If you have any particular question to be
addressed by me, you please let me know.
We'll spend some time on the examination
also.
Also on the preparation part,
how do you want to,
what are the doubts you have?
We can spend some time,
either last part of today or next week,
however you want it. Okay, yes.
So with that note,
I'll get into context engineering.
So context,
what does context actually mean?
According to me, it is a subset. Okay.
So now,
why I'm saying according to me or I'm not
giving you a clear cut
facts here because this entire
relationship between the different
engineerings plus the terms itself is
very new and they are also evolving as
the AI models are evolving,
as the entire AI engineering is evolving,
these terms context engineering.
So harness was there in February.
Today we have two more graph and loop.
So the relationship between these things
itself is not very clearly defined.
It is all based on,
there are many works which are going on
by.
various prestigious, you know,
institutions plus the industry as such.
But at this point of time,
whatever we have is opinions and inputs
from experts who are dealing with that.
So that's why we are not clearly defining
these terms tomorrow.
I'm sure there might be more terms coming
in or
Some of them might feel that all these
new terms are opinions. I mean,
even practically,
I also feel all these new terms are
nothing but revisited software
engineering in the AI era. So, I mean,
everyone will have their own opinions,
but it is important for us why I am
giving you all these new terms is.
It is important as learners who are
getting into the AI based software
engineering to understand what each of
these terms mean because we go and read.
articles, we go and have to read research,
we have to go and see case studies where
this has been implemented before.
And we might be implementing it in our
organization's workplaces.
So that time we should be able to relate
and we should be able to analyze what
they are saying.
whether it fits our product,
whether it doesn't fit our product.
So that kind of decision making,
et cetera,
will come only if you have the
understanding of what is evolving,
how they call what, et cetera.
And that is why I'm bringing in all the
new terms.
to give you all a heads up on this is how
it is evolving.
So the relationships at this point of
time,
what is available is what I'm providing.
But tomorrow,
the same term might be redefined by
different AI player in a different way as
well. Okay,
so we don't have to worry about that.
But we have to all accept the fact that
this is evolving.
And this is going to change, right?
Probably the next year or next semester
I'm going to take this course,
might completely have a new set of terms
and technologies.
We might not know how it is doing.
But at this point of time,
our focus is to understand what are the
problems, how that can be.
Put into a process in a traditional
software systems and how that can be
aligned with that. OK,
so with that context,
let's get into this context engineering.
So,
as I mentioned in the previous session as
well, context.
Engineering itself is a practice to
manage the context to the LLM or.
The relevant reliable outputs.
So, it is in a context.
When I say context,
it can be in any format,
but ultimately when it goes to the large
language model, it is a set of tokens,
right? So,
engineering problem at hand here is to
optimize the utility of those tokens
against whatever constraints of LLMs in
order to achieve a very...
What is the desired outcome for us?
So thinking in context is what the words
they use,
which means a holistic state which we are
providing to the LLM at any given time,
and that is going to affect the behavior
that state might yield and the output
coming out of them.
What?
So if you say context is not new to AI,
it existed in machine learning also.
When I talked about supervised learning,
unsupervised learning,
where we are using simple machine
learning models without the LLMs or deep
learning models, the foundation models.
There also context was there. OK, so it,
but it was more in terms of data and the
context was whatever the model sees
during the inference time,
that is when it's trying to predict value
or classify,
that is the time is what is was.
referred to as a context.
But in an LLM or in today's AI agent or
what, AI engineering,
context doesn't only include.
everything, what the model sees,
but it also includes that system prompts,
which you might have it as a default
instructions and the rules,
the user prompt or the user query,
and other documents which you are going
to pass from either through RAJ based
systems or from the vector database.
Or from maybe you can also have, say,
a MCP. I'll talk about MCP also today.
How do you connect to external tools?
So you get some data from those tools and
you pass it.
So that also is included in the context.
So any data which you cut.
passing in a structured format in JSON,
CSV or schemas. And a few history,
the history of the interactions also.
plus the output of any additional systems
such as agent outputs,
maybe another agent is giving you some
response tools which are providing you
some data.
So all this is what context refers to.
And why context engineering?
is important is to build capable agents,
right?
It involves structuring how information
to, I mean,
what kind of information to include in
the context and what is necessary.
We have a limitation.
So I say give the most important
information, right?
That important word is very important
because the context window is fixed.
So I cannot, if I'm going to do something,
everything put it into it and just ask
this, ask it to do it,
it's not going to give me the right
output.
So we cannot give everything what we have.
We have to structure it, right?
So what happens in that structuring?
What is important?
How do we find the most semantic
similarity document, right?
There has to be some, you might have 15.
Say, let's say, for example,
there are 15 sources,
PDF files you have on your spec or some
inputs from your organization.
Out of that 15,
what is semantically relevant to your
question which you are asking right now
is something which the model has to
figure out.
Right,
I mean the model will not figure out,
but something it has to be figured out
before the.
All the 15 documents go to the LLM,
so if you are going to pick out only the
semantic relevant documents and then give
only what is necessary in the context,
then the model will work within the
context window and it will also provide
you more.
correct reliable outputs. So that is what,
how do you put that? I'm just saying 15,
say 5 out of 15,
but how do you choose that 5 out of 15
documents? It's not only documents, right?
It is about many other things like what
are the rules you have to pass.
So harness we discussed, right?
There are many.
or whatever we discussed in the harness,
I go back to the diagram to recollect.
So these principles, CFRs, rules,
reference document, many guides are there.
So all these guides which you want to
feed forward, that's the context.
But how do you put...
So you're not going to put everything in
every request, right? It's going to,
when you're defining specs or
architecture,
architecture related rules is important.
But when you're going to do the testing,
you are not going to put the design based
rules there. So what are you going to do?
How are you going to put that context
right?
That is where context engineering is
going to play a major.
A role, and that's where.
It is actually different from harness
engineering, right?
So agents needs to perform a task and
context is giving them the information,
right? And why it is important?
Because it's building the agents, right?
So the...
current memory, the short-term memory.
We humans also have short-term memory.
What you are listening at this point of
time, I'm in this class,
I'm actually talking to a set of learners.
So that's my short-term memory.
Then there is long-term memory, et cetera.
Like, so, context.
itself is the memory window.
How are we going to, in very simple words,
there is a memory window.
What are the things we are going to put
into that memory window in the right way
so that we get the best output?
That is what context engineering is about,
right? So LLMs have an attention budget.
Because when parsing large number of
content, they cannot do.
We looked at few problems, what happens?
They forget something in the middle.
So those problems also we looked at.
So that is where a context engineering
comes in.
So it's done in a very structured way.
So these are the steps.
For context engineering,
it starts with selection.
You choose what information to include in
the context.
You filter out irrelevant or redundant
data based on either ranking and you
reduce the context window to fit the
current task. This also prevents other...
So when I say selection,
the security aspects,
so always remember security is not an
afterthought at all, right?
So whatever task we do in an SDLC,
security has to be one of the quality
attributes.
That is something we cannot ignore or we
cannot take it lightly.
So now when I say context selection also,
it doesn't just taking up the right input
for the context.
It also involves ensuring that inaccurate
or malicious information doesn't go.
enter into the context window.
So when I say that security,
it is not only the attacks.
You passing out information, your PII,
personal information of the product or
the customers accidentally to the AI is
also a
security problem, right?
So the context engineer who's working
should ensure that PII information or any
secrets of your APIs or other things are
not getting into the window,
plus malicious attacks.
So how do we ensure that there is no...
any kind of prompt injection which is
happening by someone, etc.
So that also involves,
when you say context selection,
it is not only choosing the right
information,
it is also preventing incorrect or
inaccurate or malicious information
getting into the system.
And then comes the structuring part.
So structuring is,
we now have no what all to be given.
So how do we give it? Right,
we might use data formats like markdown,
JSON to define the instructions.
Then I will come to prompting strategy.
So there are a few prompt strategies
which separates instruction from the data.
And we have to structure it.
How do you pack it?
Like when you are packing for your travel,
first we know what are the items we need
to take. So we collate all that, right?
But we have only one suitcase,
means we have to pack it within that
suitcase, right?
So we have to fix everything within that.
We have to pack it so that we are able to
close the suitcase,
plus we are able to take it as well.
So that is what structuring majorly
brings in.
And then comes the prong design and
engineering. So a little elaborate,
we will discuss on prong design and
engineering.
how the instructions are framed.
Right,
so you'll see a overlap between context
structuring and prompt design engineering.
But when I say prompt design and
engineering,
it's basically only the instructions and
rules included.
and how do you want the output to be?
How do you want to provide the
instructions and how do you want the
output to be?
And I say context structuring,
it is not only the instructions,
but additional whatever information you
want to pass to the model. Okay,
so maybe prompt design and engineering
can also be a subset of
context structuring itself also.
But we are focusing that specifically
because that was the first thing,
a very important prompt engineering
aspect which came out immediately after
the AI LLMs were available for users,
even before context engineering came,
harness engineering came, etc.
Context prompt engineering was the best.
or the simplest way in which we can fine
tune. I should not use the word fine tune.
Front engineering is a way out which we
can help the model to become more useful,
reliable outputs without getting into the
model itself, right?
So then comes the compression part,
where you include techniques for fitting
more useful information into the limited
token space.
how do you compression algorithms you use
or summarization would you like to ensure
maybe summarizing some informations or I
think few places they are also testing
compression algorithms like Huffman
encoding and all so that a more better
way the information can get into the
system.
So this is 1 area we are not getting into
detail,
but I'm giving you the crux or the
importance of it.
Like we have a data and we want to pass
everything.
They are obviously going to read it in
tokens, embedded vectors only later.
So can we do some compression there so
that they can.
or understand the output, et cetera.
And sequencing,
what information should go first.
So how many of you know CSS cascading
style sheets?
Have any of you worked on cascading style
sheets?
Okay, Sirisha says yes. Okay,
so then you know the rules, right?
The cascading rules.
Then what everyone designs their own
systems and they pass that. But cascading,
the CSS actually identifies which rule
matches.
and then applies only that rule.
So there is a priority,
the cascade algorithm itself is,
it is how that,
like you have all the rules,
all the rules are nothing but
instructions today.
You know what to apply on one rule will
override the other rule. Yes?
So similar to that,
the LLMs also are going to receive system
prompts.
They are going to receive
platform-related instructions.
They are going to receive user-related
instructions. They are going to receive...
Um...
system prompts as such.
So how is it going to actually decide
which one it should follow in case if
there is a contradicting thing, right?
So that is where this sequencing and the
rules,
the most relevant context will come in.
But the model itself will have
capabilities to figure out, okay?
So when you discuss prompt engineering,
I will share.
a few things on open AI,
how it looks at different roles,
et cetera. But there might be information,
the model itself,
some of the models or all models that
today have the capability to resolve such
conflicts or they have an order in which
they will prioritize.
So platform level prompts.
are given the first importance,
then the system, then the user.
That is how it is,
especially if you have mentioned roles.
I think many of you would have heard this.
When you write prompts,
please write roles.
I think that is 1 input you would have
seen if you have read anything about
prompt engineering or if you have a...
Um, taken some courses on that, etcetera,
right? Why do they say those right roles,
etcetera,
because when you give a role to that
particular, um...
prompt or the AI model itself,
it puts you a little above in the
priority stack. So platform level,
system level, then the roles,
then the final user.
So when you say as a developer,
automatically it goes a little high in
the stack and it gives you better
instruction.
outputs because the instructions are
treated a little in priority.
So that is why they say put a role
whenever you write a prompt,
so it's better to give it, right?
So that is on the model part.
The model itself, based on the prompt,
it will prioritize.
But in sequencing also, we can.
the prompts, what rules should go first,
what are the system prompt might have
many rules,
but what actually is needed here, right?
The most relevant content should be there
on the top.
Deeper history or less important
information can go back in the further
window.
So that is also something which you can
control.
through the sequencing. And of course,
how do you put all this together?
The various tools, MCT will come here.
How are you going to integrate other
information, the tool calling,
what they generally say now,
how the model can talk to other tools.
Instead of it having all the data,
how it can go and talk to someone,
get the data, and then based on that,
provide the inference, right? So,
these are the steps which are involved in
context engineering, as very over, I mean,
I have given a very briefly, it is.
We can have an entire course on this.
That's how that's elaborate it is.
And these are the concepts.
Retrieval is the first part, generation,
processing, and management.
So when I say retrieval,
it is pulling out relevant information to
include in the model, searching databases,
knowledge bases.
keyword matching, semantic similarity.
I mean,
these are all names I'm giving you,
but there can be hybrid approaches that
combine best of all this.
And the idea of context retrieval is to
ensure that the model has the...
accurate, relevant,
and up-to-date information.
In simple words, that is how it is.
Generation is how do you construct or
transform information that is suitable
for the model or easily interpretable for
the model, especially our...
documents or human data which we have at
hand today are too large or noisy and
unstructured. Right?
So it can be long documents,
it can be key facts.
That can be any type,
but our general data is noisy and
unstructured.
So even in machine learning or if you
look at data mining also,
you'll have this data cleaning process.
Like what is data cleaning?
We say is it's a data plane processing.
Data pre-processing, what we do,
we ensure that the data is processed in a
way that is useful for the model.
So something on similar lines is content
generation.
You see whether the entire document can
be passed or can you extract the facts.
conversation history,
and you can retrieval documents,
determine what information is selected,
generation documents,
determine how that information is shaped
and presented.
If the retrieval brings in low quality
data,
Even well-structured context generation
cannot fully compensate that. Okay,
so the both these are very interdependent
on each other, the quality wise,
and then the processing processing again
retrieve data and intermediary.
information,
how do you provide into a language model,
right?
So basically this is the bridge which
acts between the retrieval and the
context generation. So how do you get,
you have the not clean data.
selective data,
but how are you going to go into the
generation phase, right?
So that path it leads is the processing.
So you chunk, you segment it,
you divide it, then you rank it,
you filter it, remove redundancies,
prioritize important facts.
or you reorder,
you have some ranking based on which you
will reorder that.
Then you also will transform data to
JSON-like representation or into a
labeled text.
You might be adding annotations,
metadata to it, and then compression.
You might have limited context windows,
so you might involve summarizing or
condensing information into a smaller
size.
And all this you have to do.
In alignment with the...
consistent with the instructions,
reduce ambiguity,
all that are something which you have to
take care by doing all this, right?
So context processing is something which
leads you from the retrieval to the
context generation phase.
And context management is the...
A process of controlling all this
together, deciding what to retain,
I mean everything, what all retrieval,
generation and processing,
all this together is the management part
and all this together is what is called
as context.
Engineering, right? So now,
this context engineering leads us to
understand two more important concepts,
which is the prompt engineering and RAP.
So,
data retrieval is the central con to the
context engineering, right?
Because.
It determines what and how external
information is going into the models,
but during the inference time on the
working context,
so all whatever we discussed,
managing the context window.
selecting the relevant context, etc.
Plus,
you are also not only working on prompt
here.
There are two aspects into the context.
So what exactly is the context?
System prompt, user prompt,
additional knowledge information we are
saying, right? So there are two things.
One is the prompts,
which are going to the model.
plus the other information.
So the other information what we are
talking is provided in terms of dynamic
knowledge access is provided in form of
RAC, Retrieval Augmented Generation.
So instead of completely relying on the
data in which the model was trained on,
right, LLM.
all LLMs have been trained exclusively,
but they have been trained on some data.
But then for us to use only what they
have been trained on,
we did not get sufficient results or we
did not get,
we faced a lot of hallucination problems.
it drifting from the actual problem, etc.
So that is where we needed a RAJ layer,
which provides the model with additional
dynamic knowledge in addition to what it
has been trained on,
so that up to date domain specific
information at runtime.
This capability was a very important
capability in use enterprise use cases or
any use case,
where the most valuable knowledge resides
outside.
It doesn't take the memory aspects.
It doesn't require us to retrain the
model again and again.
But it is resided outside,
but it can be given to the model at the
right time, so that was RAJ,
which we will talk about a little in
detail. So,
RAJ information also goes to the model,
plus promptings, prompt data, right? So,
understanding.
This what goes into the model that is
very important.
So 2 main aspects is prompt and brand,
right?
Now, to understand this entire RAJ,
or even not I will drag to understand the
entire context engineering, right?
One important thing you have to
understand is the data formats.
Like,
understanding databases and data formats
is a very important skill to do context
engineering.
Why I'm actually bringing this point here
is...
Some of us might think that the databases
are now handled in a different way.
We might not need the older databases or,
I mean,
we are moving into different vector
databases, etc. But still,
our entire legacy.
systems or what we use today are there in
the modeling,
are there in the traditional databases.
So databases form a very important skill
which anyone who's working on a context
engineering should know,
how information is stored, retrieved,
structured.
and provided.
All this are going to take a lot of
learning from relational databases,
NoSQL databases, vector databases,
embeddings,
even search engines such as Elasticsearch.
So our data is going to be huge, right?
So how are you going to have a keyboard?
keyword based search or a semantic based
search, et cetera.
So even those search engines such as
elastic search,
all those going to be useful.
Graph databases,
because now we have next to,
I'm going to show you graph engineering
also. So there are knowledge graphs,
recommendation systems.
So many things are coming in.
Right, so then JSON, XML,
so databases and data formats.
A very important skill to get into the
context engineering part. OK, right,
so I see some.
I have studied about transfer learning in
neural networks.
Sorry, AI.
Is it similar to that means are you
referring to the context engineering I'm
talking about?
I missed where did you ask this question?
So, transfer learning, as far as I know,
it is about you are learning the data in
one context,
but you are applying it to the different
contexts, right?
So for example,
the very basic example they give in
transfer learning is you have learned one
music instruments and you have had a
basic, say I learned to,
I learned piano or some basic music
instrument.
I learned something while I was focused
only on learning the piano or the
keyboard.
There are some parts which I understand
about music which I can apply to learn
another music instrument. Right?
So that is what is transfer learning in
simple terms.
Um...
You are asking whether transfer learning
is related to RAJ. OK, I would say no. OK,
according to me,
transfer learning is more of getting into
the model.
It's a machine learning technique where
the model.
inference from the data, right? Basically,
it understands some patterns from one
model, one set of data.
It reuses that learning.
when it is actually learning from the
other set of data.
Right, so,
so that is where the difference comes.
I would not say RAJ is similar to
transfer learning. It's not.
Okay, so there is a fine line,
or I would say not only related to
Sushil's question,
but all of us should understand AIML
engineering is getting into the model.
doing some things which will improve the
model's output, modifying the weights,
adding parameters, fine-tuning it.
pre-training it or optimizing it.
So there are many things you can do into
the model so that it is suitable for your
use case. The line,
what we are focusing here in SDLC mostly,
is we are treating the model as a black
box, right? And we are using it.
And what all we are doing around the
model to ensure that it is used in our
system,
either it is used as an augmentation
across all SDLC phase,
or we are also having the AI model as a
part of our application,
like we are building AI agents or based
applications, whatever.
But we are using the model,
so we are not getting into the fine
tuning part, etc.
So that is where the entire software
engineering and whatever all we are
discussing will revolve around. Okay? Yes.
RAJ is the data we provide. No,
that is not the data based on it is
trained. So as I explained, the line is.
To the model outside the model,
so we are not touching the model.
The model is a black box to us.
We know when it is given a prompt,
it will give us the output, right?
But how do we provide the output? Sorry,
how do we provide the input in a more?
optimized, structured,
and efficient way that it gives us the
best reliable output.
That is what we are focusing in terms of
harness is also same,
context is also same.
Everything is outside the model.
We are not getting to anything inside the
model. Even RAJ is outside the model.
Whatever you retrieve,
so RANGNATH itself is retrieval,
Augmented generation, right?
So you retrieve, you chunk it,
you have chunks of vector database
information,
all that is getting generated in a
structured way, and it goes as a.
input to the LLM.
It is not trained on the LLM. It doesn't,
it's not pre,
it's not even getting into the model base
or it is not even getting into anything
to process the LLM.
It stops one layer above.
Okay,
I think that answered all your questions.
Right? So that's a very important thing.
I think I have one slide in our today's
session, which gives this difference,
because that's one area which all of us
get a little carried out when we leave.
learn too many new things, right?
It's easy to drift from humans also like
AI into the other aspects.
Right,
so prompt engineering is creating an LLM
prompt that will lead to better output.
I would say it is a subset of context
engineering, narrower in scope.
It doesn't address the other information
the LLM can see.
It only addresses the prompt.
RAB focuses on a way to...
add information from other places,
database,
other documents to the LLM context window,
it doesn't get into the prompt side. Okay,
so the context is prompt plus RANGNATH.
We can say like that. How message history,
whatever you discussed in the past,
will be stored in some
cache there.
So how that information or how API we
might be calling some tools or API or
document databases,
how that information is getting into the
model, all that is what RAJ focuses on.
Whereas the prompt is focused by prompt
engineering.
Right, so that is the basic difference.
Now coming to prompt engineering, right?
So this is something when AI became a top
of the town or when it started actually
building up all these things.
Prompt engineering was the first thing
which everyone started doing,
or it was one of the useful thing in
which you can get better outputs from the
AI.
So, prompt engineering.
is basically the science plus art.
I would say it's not only science because
it's not structured of how you write
prompts to the AI models so that they can
give you better outputs.
So by carefully doing some crafting there,
you provide the model with context
instructions and examples so that it can
understand. Okay,
so basically how you can look at this
entire thing is when we started giving
instructions to the model, right?
Leave model, when we had our processors.
How did we give instructions to the
processor? We had add, sum, multiply.
We had those basic mission and mission
level instructions we are giving,
assembly level instructions, right?
So we were talking in the terms of how
the computer was talking, how the...
processor was talking.
So the processor has a limited vocabulary.
It understands only this.
So we were writing programs,
machine level instructions,
then we started writing assembly level
instructions because the vocabulary of
the program.
processing unit increased,
and then in compilers.
So the vocabulary again expanded to more
syntax, programming constructs, right?
So it understood if, it understood while,
it understood for loops.
So we started writing programs in a way
it was understanding.
So, all these humans have gone to.
Talk in terms of the language of the.
Machine we are using, right?
So then we had low level languages,
then high level languages,
then we had many abstract languages,
so that there was a lot of evolutions
which were happening there.
We were always writing instructions to
the...
processing units or to the computer in
terms of their vocabulary,
what they had understanding. Now,
when it comes to prompt,
you can see it has one more evolution
apart from the high level language.
It is an evolution of the
Natural language,
we are not constraining the vocabulary
only to what the missions can understand.
Now,
we are making the language we talk to the
systems as our natural language itself,
right? So,
when we say our language is our natural
language, the way we talk...
To or may we provide instructions to the
computer or to the model is a natural
language itself,
the vocabulary expands in size.
Right,
so now we don't have a compiler is going
to struggle with that, right?
Compiler is a very definite,
deterministic set.
It has it is defined on basic rules and
abstract syntax tree, etc. But now,
how can you design a compiler which talks?
or understands all the natural language.
That is going to be difficult,
and that is where AI models have achieved.
So they can understand natural language,
and they have a way in which they can
understand natural language. They come,
they look at your words, they...
break down them into tokens,
then they do a semantic analysis of it.
then they convert it into embeddings.
So all those natural language processing
techniques plus the transformers,
how do they find relevant information and
predict the next word,
all that technology comes in.
But when we are talking to humans,
itself. So when I'm talking to you.
I talk in a way which I'm capable of.
Plus,
I also ensure that I talk in a way that
all of you can understand. Like,
I don't use,
even if I know advanced language words,
I don't use all of them.
the class because it has to resonate with
who the listeners.
If I'm going to teach a five-year-old kid,
I have to talk in their terms.
Right?
So if I'm going to talk to a person who's
verbally good in a native language but
not well versed in English,
I have to talk in that local language for
them to understand whenever we are giving
instruction.
So prompt engineering is very in simple
terms.
It is that.
you're not just randomly giving some
instructions,
you are structuring the information in a
better way. Okay,
so I would say it is a new age
programming model.
So earlier programs we were writing with
basic syntax and semantics of that
language.
Now,
prompt engineering is programming of
natural language.
That is how you should see it.
And there are best rules which have come
out. How do you craft better so that...
the model gives the reliable output.
So what is crafting,
where these best practices come from is,
how the models have been developed.
Open AI has developed the model in one
way. While developing the model,
they have said,
give more importance to system prompts,
platform prompts.
the user wherever the role is there,
give this kind of an importance,
prioritize it.
So there has been some basic way in which
the prompts have been,
the model has been developed, right?
So we get to know those information and
we craft our prompts in accordance with
that.
That is what entire prompt engineering.
Is that all? And prompt engineering,
I would say, is 1 non-technical.
You don't have to be.
Highly technical to understand prompt
engineering.
It is one way in which AI usage has been
democratized.
If you have put another JSON structure or
a YAML structure today, we most of us.
talk to or provide instructions to
missions in YAML or JSON, right?
So they are also simple text.
It is not having hard fast rules like the
C programming or object-oriented or even
in Python in that case have.
It's very simple, right?
But YAML or JSON also had a defined
structure.
which didn't reach one layer about the IT
industry or CS industry, I would say.
But prompt engineering is what made the
other sectors who are not technical in
the computer science or in the IT also to
look at AI. Because
It is nothing but writing in your natural
language itself,
but of course with a structure which is
more efficient for the model to process.
So that's what the entire prompt
engineering is about. And
Now, there are many strategies,
like when I say prompt,
it has a description.
It has.
It is an instruction for a model to
perform. So say I have this prompt,
given a text, extract all entities,
output the list of extracted entities
separated by commas and nothing else.
So this is the description I give.
And this is the example text.
I have given right,
so now the task is to separate all the
entities out from this and output it.
So here,
the way we give instructions can get into
some strategies or some ideas we can get,
right? So these are the terms,
zero shot prompting, few shot prompting,
chain of thought prompting.
All these are some inputs,
strategies we can follow.
to serve to each AI, right?
So when why do we need this or why do we
need prompt engineering as such is the
structure plus the style.
They provide a significant role in the AI
response. Okay, and this is not fixed.
Okay,
different models based on how they are
developed respond to specific prompts as
such. But majorly,
these are some common among all the
models.
So the structure of the prompt plays a
significant role in how the AI interprets
your
request, right?
So providing the context and relevant
examples within your prompt will help AI
understand the desired task much more,
better, and give you relevant outputs.
So if you're looking for a story, right,
for example, I'm prompting.
for a creating or a creative story.
If you can describe a few sentences,
the tone of the story or theme,
it can significantly give you a better
output.
Hey.
So,
it is basically improving the model's
output.
by providing a set of structured
information, et cetera.
And these are some of the techniques.
First is zero shot or direct prompts.
It is direct information question without
adding any example or anything.
So that is the zero shot prompting.
where the model is prompted to create or
generate ideas.
Wherever you have simple summarization,
translation, in such content,
zero-shot prompting is sufficient.
Then comes one shot, few shot,
and multiple.
Multi-shot prompts. Generally,
this is called a few-shot prompting.
This method provides the model with one
or more examples of the desired
input-output pairs before giving the
actual prompt. So,
this helps the model to understand the
task better and generate more accurate.
Responses, so that is on few short,
and so you give the model while you give
the model,
you also mention that this is how it
should look like, or you specify that.
This is how the output input should look
like. So it understands the task better.
And chain of thought is something we saw
in the reasoning models also.
It encourages the model to break down a
complex reasoning into a series of
intermediary steps.
So it gives us a better, well-structured
final output, right?
And there are a few combinations of these
strategies, like for example,
zero-shot chain of thought prompts
combines chain of thought prompting with
zero-shot prompting by asking the model
to perform reasoning steps by giving you
the output.
Good, etcetera.
So these are some methods and the
strategies, if you say each of them,
there are many strategies by many people.
I'm not getting into that,
but there are many strategies.
Some of them say use the CRISP one,
that is RACE, ROSE.
There are many terms they come up,
many acronyms are there in prompt
engineering.
But if you combine and see all that,
one is build clear goals and objectives,
provide some background like few shot
prompting, etc. Be very specific,
iterate and experiment. And you can,
if it's a complex problem,
please leverage on the chain of thought.
So that is the best way.
Where you can work, OK?
I will give you one document.
That's for your understanding.
You don't have to get into detailed of
that.
That is how Open AI sees different.
I couldn't figure out.
I will share it later.
I think I just saved the document,
but I will send it to you.
It is basically how open AI sees
different roles, user roles,
different roles, etc.
So that will give you an idea why the
assistant prompt or the developer prompt.
is very important, right? So it gives you.
..
A kind of an idea.
Yeah,
I will look at it and share the document
a little later.
Yeah, many reach. Yeah,
I'll see some questions now. Reach prompt.
I think there are many.
I'm not sure what is reach prompt
technique,
but there are many prompt techniques. OK,
one is crisp is something which we keep
telling. I have seen many.
People,
they Chris Piping stands for Context Role,
forgot.
So there are many prompting techniques.
This is 1, I think the role context,
some statements, example,
I think that is how it is.
But there are many prompting techniques
available. So I mean,
all these are ways in which how you can
structure the prompt.
Okay,
so one thing I should tell you is as
engineers, as software engineers,
or someone working in these lines,
we should remember the problem is not
with prompt engineering.
It's a very really useful skill.
But with what we are having today,
AI agents,
Prompt engineering alone is not
sufficient. Okay,
prompt engineering is just a part of it.
So I see that many are focusing too much
on the prompt engineering.
However effective you define your prompts,
there is a limitation.
So we should go beyond the prompt context
harness is where we should have more
focus, not only on the prompt side.
I'm not saying prompt engineering is not
important, but there is a limitation.
It only works with that set of text.
Right, but there's much more to it,
so that is something we should focus on,
OK?
Yes,
prompt caching is also a part of prompt
engineering. So prompt caching,
I would say, when you say prompt caching,
I think you are talking about the KV
caches where the LLMs.
can store. So if that is the case,
then it is inside the model.
So you can also have a harness,
something externally to cache important
context, et cetera. But prompt caching,
basically, there is
store the tokens which are generated.
They are stored in a key value cache,
which is.
Oh, my screen is not visible. Sorry.
Just the sharing.
Thanks.
Okay, so when I talk about,
I was talking about caching, right?
So the...
Tokens are nothing but data generated,
tokens generated from the inputs, right?
So prompt caching stores the intermediary
values of an LLM's input to reduce the
latency and token cost for repeated
queries, etc.
So yes,
so that is where you can do a prompt
cache.
So there is a KV cache which comes in.
It is a very good strategy, I would say.
It actually caches certain things.
Um...
so that you don't have to repeat.
Repeated LLM prompts,
especially system related prompts, right?
All these are have doesn't have to be
broken into tokens again and again,
so that is,
or sometimes the the how the tokens are
divided, plus there is something on.
certain parameters,
the top T parameters based on the
transformer model works, right?
So there also,
if all the parameters are same,
you don't have to rework on certain
things. So prompt caching comes in.
So there is,
but it gets a little inside the model
there, but here.
I mean,
I'll to answer your Saurav's question,
it is completely not prompt engineering.
I would say it is a little about prompt
engineering also.
Depending on where you are caching,
how we were actually doing it.
So because some information,
prompt engineering stops at the prompt
level,
but some information to be used in prompt
caching also requires the parameters of
the model. So how do you structure them?
How do you provide that data to them also
comes in.
Data, and does always so.
Yes,
prompt engineering is dependent on the
LLM model. Yes.
Different models treated different
prompts differently.
So we have to have an understanding of
how the model is trained.
So that is why we should look at the
developer documents of the model to
understand how they interpret the prompts.
Is markdown similar to JSON or YML? No.
Markdown is not exactly similar.
It is different. So when I say markdown,
it includes all of our AI generated.
or whatever files we are getting
generated, right? So when I say JSON,
it's a, I mean,
I would say they are different formats.
Both are lightweight, of course.
JSON was compared lightweight than the
previous.
One which we had, etcetera, right?
So it is basically different, that's all.
I mean,
I didn't understand what context you
asked it. Like,
will the models treated differently or if
that is the context, then we have to see.
I mean, I'm not very sure how each model.
We'll see, but most of the,
at this point in time,
if you see markdowns are mostly used for
context.
They are good at understanding it.
And JSON is mostly used for execution API.
I mean, it is used in terms of execution.
When AI talks to.
external tools, etc. JSON is what is used.
If that is the, I mean,
that is the general usage because of its
nature of the data format. Markdown, JSON,
YAML are different data formats.
And where it is used, if you ask me,
JSON is used mainly in tool called.
when AI wants to talk to external tools,
external APIs, et cetera.
And markdown is used in terms of context.
Okay, so system prompt and user prompt,
this is a difference.
The instructions provided by the
application developers are put into the
system prompt.
By instructions from the end user are put
into the.
User prompt.
Say you are building an AI agent for your
say you are having an application which
has AI part. OK,
so the user is giving some information if
that information has go to the.
LLM, and it has to come out,
but there are certain things you want to
control,
but that is where you put it in the
system prompt,
so that the instructions are given in a
right way.
Right, so one.
Example is, say there is a library.
And there is an AI based assistant for a
library.
The user might ask,
give me a book written by this particular
author.
The AI will give that details of the book,
whether it is available,
all that by looking at some database, etc.
The AI will also have access to the
online copies of the book, right?
So if a user prompts asking,
give me the text of the first chapter.
Of the book,
the AI should not actually hit it.
It is a violation.
It it comes under.
Confidential information,
or it comes under the...
non-disclosure information, right?
The contents of the book cannot be given
in an AI chat. It has to be,
it follows certain rules.
It can refer to it,
it can provide you data based on what it
is trained,
but it cannot give you the chapters of
the book.
Exactly, right? So in that case,
AI should say I am not allowed to do that,
right?
So if you just pass user prompts to the
AI, it will stop.
It will not have this kind of an
understanding.
It will just do what the user is asking.
So that is where the system level prompts
will play.
And the CSS example I told you,
it knows which,
how to prioritize which will override
what. So that is how AI also will do.
So system level prompts obviously will
have a higher priority and preference.
So that will obviously override the user
prompts,
even if the user says provide me the
textbook.
They will not drop it.
So that is the idea behind these prompts.
So I hope you got the relationships or
difference between context prompt
engineering and harness engineering.
So prompt is you just give the message.
To the...
AI.
So if the entire AI engineering started
with prompt engineering only,
then slowly it is evolving into new terms
every month. So as Mr.
Abhinav has mentioned,
every day new terms are coming up.
It's quite true.
Today we have two more new terms.
I had harness engineering is what I
planned when I wanted to start this
course.
But today we have two more terms,
loop engineering and graph engineering
also. So that is how it is actually going.
So we might not know whether these,
I mean,
today it looks like all these are new
terms, old wine in the new bottle,
that's how it looks.
just software engineering redesigned or
renamed for the AI based systems and AI
Augmented systems. That's how it looks,
but let's see how it,
if there are entirely new terms to call
them new technology. I'm not at.
I mean,
there are no convincing reasoning at this
point in time.
Let's see how it progresses.
But this is how it is.
So, RAJ,
I will talk about a little more in detail.
So,
before I will pause here for some
questions, any confusions or anything,
any clarity? Yeah,
tone is also one type of data format.
That's right.
On this protocol,
when you talk to DIP systems,
they have that very strict form,
and so is another one.
So basically, tune was,
they say tune is basically it reduces the
number of tokens.
So it is more token oriented.
Probably they would have removed a few.
No, curly braces,
I think I'm not exactly sure,
but I'm just guessing.
And one thing I will tell you,
it is not necessary that we should know
all things, right? Okay.
So when I say context engineering or RAJ,
it is not necessary that we should have
look at, because all the,
today we will have so much content.
Plus, there are so many evolutions.
Some will stand the test of time,
some will not. So it's okay. I mean,
certain things, if you don't get, I mean,
we don't read everything or we don't
understand everything,
it's completely fine because this is a
very...
interesting phase plus a challenging
phase also because everything is evolving.
Not only the AI side is evolving,
with the AI,
other phases are also evolving.
The way they did software engineering is
evolving and the model is also evolving.
I have a beautiful diagram.
which I have planned in today's class.
I don't mind stopping the sharing and
going into that.
Big deal.
That I'm basically.
This should have been my diagram,
which I had shown in the very first class,
but I read it very recently. So the AI.
How AI is transforming organizations,
right?
the adoption, right?
It is not happening in one dimension.
It is happening in multiple dimensions.
Here they have mentioned 2 dimensions,
right? So you initially have...
Ohh.
Traditional systems,
traditional development phase,
and even I can say deployment also,
but here they have not gone into the
deployment angle,
but say traditional systems and
traditional development. Now,
if you go into the AI augmentation and
creation,
our systems are traditional systems,
maybe I'm still developing a.
hotel booking system or I'm still
developing a simple traditional flight
booking system, etc.
Or I'm managing it still,
legacy systems are there.
I'm not planning to bring in any AI
components to it,
but still I'm using AI for the
development phase.
So we are using AI co-pilots,
we are using testing, code generation,
design support.
We might be including a few AI enabled
features just for certain places, etc.
So this is also evolving, right?
All of our systems.
We had a simple e-commerce application,
but there is a recommendation engine
coming there. Or else we had a simple.
learning management system we had.
But again,
there is a chat bot which was there for
very long years.
Now we are having more on top of it.
We are having a few analytics built on
top of it.
We are having AI based recommendations,
all that is coming in.
So this part is also evolving.
Right, this part is also important.
We had simple systems,
but we are having more AI systems.
AI systems with traditional development
was there before the LLM era,
the ChatGPT era. We didn't use...
We were developing a lot of AI systems,
so we were using our traditional
development model only, right? So,
an AI engineer will focus on improving
the model, fine tuning the model,
optimizing the model to the better output,
they will be changing the parameters, etc.
Fine,
and then there is a software engineer who
comes in, does whatever he does usually,
and then I add the model to it.
That is what we have been doing till
before this entire agents or generated AI
came in.
So that is where the role of AI engineers
and...
ML engineers were clear,
had a we had a very clear segregation.
If you look at the AI ML engineers,
they will not be there in any of the
product discussions at all.
They were hardly called in for any.
project-based discussions,
or they were very less involved in that,
right? The role and building ML models,
then there were data engineers who
focused only on the data,
they how what kind of data should go into
the model before an appropriate model is
used.
all that. If they were focusing,
then they were engineers and the software
engineers start constructed systems.
But now we are having, we are this,
we are heading towards this space.
So we are evolving in this dimension,
we are evolving in this dimensions,
multiple dimensions we are evolving.
Right, so that is where the, I mean,
too many terms coming out today.
One is getting irrelevant.
So prompt engineering is not very,
I will not say it is bond,
but the term is now more expanded in
terms of context engineering,
harness engineering. But prompt is,
prompt engineering,
whatever we did in prompt engineering is
still relevant.
But we need to do much more than what
just working on the prompts.
So that is why it is evolving.
So just because we are evolving on
multiple dimensions,
we are in such a situation.
And what we have is all experiences,
what are these experiences,
which experiences are going to stand.
the test of time,
what are going to sustain is something
which we have to wait and only see. Right,
of course,
there are a few predictions how it will
turn out, but...
The first principles are always going to
stay back.
So we should concentrate on that is what
I would say.
Right, so let me, with that,
if there are no other questions,
let me get into the RANGNATH pattern.
I come back to this complexity matrix
shortly.
Somehow in teams when multiple PPTs are
present in slideshow mode,
so the system goes into a.
Please stick, I don't know.
So,
coming to RAJ retrieval Augmented
generation, here again,
there are multiple.
Evolutions which have happened,
and you will see different types of RAJ.
I think last time I read there was 7 to 8,
et cetera. OK,
so you'll have a separate course,
or you can take up some AI systems course
where you can learn about different RAJ,
et cetera.
So, hope I'm not getting into that,
but basically it is 3 steps.
Uhh.
Injection, take the documents,
segment them into chunks,
and save it in the vector databases.
Then, when the question is asked.
Pull out the most relevant chunks using
some semantic similarity,
cosine similarity,
there are multiple algorithms,
pull out what is best, retrieve it,
then add that whatever you have retrieved
as the top important ones,
add that to the prompt and give it to the.
LLM. The LLM takes care of the generation.
The LLM reads the custom prompts and
gives the input.
So that's what brand means.
So you have a prompt plus query coming in.
Right, Miss.
Goes to the RAJ system,
searches for the relevant information,
and that comes here. So,
the initial prompt plus query,
all that together,
enhanced context is what is given to be
LLM model,
and you get the output before even this
query comes in.
Or what data it?
is comes in,
there is some processing which should
happen.
So all your documents which you want to
pass is divided into chunks and stored in
vector databases. And when you search,
this is where the performance of RAJ will
play a major role.
How does it fetch the relevant documents?
Semantic similarity, cosine similarity.
There are many,
many retrieval options which are
available.
So how efficient is going to fetch the
top important chunks of data?
That is what the major.
Thing about RAM, it's OK,
so there are many.
Rag options we have today.
So different types of rags are there.
They call it an agentic rag,
they call it a conversational rag,
then graph based rag. So, I mean, I mean,
I'm myself not very experienced in those
things.
etc. I have not worked.
I have a basic simple name.
RAJ is what I have worked with.
So basically, this is what I understand.
The advanced RAJ concepts,
how the advancement I can tell you is in
the terms of how do they chunk.
into meaningful sections so that the
precision can be improved, right,
and re-ranking.
How do you ensure that the ranking is
given in a right way so that you can
build more relevant information and
optimize that information? That is what
the advancements are all about.
And they have come up with other aspects
like graph RAJ is you store the entire
information in form of a graph so that
the knowledge graph can give you better
enhanced retrieval.
So that is some area which always.
even AIs,
there are many AI models which work on
based on graph based information, etc.
So graph is something and there are
hybrid rags which are combination of all
that. And agentic rag is like,
it doesn't stop with all the information
here.
Whatever we are saying, right?
It's not only documents or knowledge
sources.
It's not persistent here.
They can also talk to an AI.
or they can call an external database for
immediate reasoning, etc.
So it's not just this research
information.
When it is just talking to a set of
vector databases alone,
we call it as a simple graph.
And instead of
performing a single retrieval query,
then this particular search relevant
information, say,
assume this is a simple search,
but assume if this is an AI agent in
itself, right,
that becomes an agentic wrap.
So what agentic wrap will do is it will
go and fetch.
relevant information from external places,
APIs, database queries for the,
to give the most relevant information.
And it is iterative in nature.
So it can go back to the LLM agent and it
can see that, okay,
certain informations are not.
relevant, et cetera, or it needs,
there are some missing information,
it can come back again,
get that data before producing the final
output. Of course, when I say this itself,
all of you would have guessed it is
increased cost, computational cost,
architectural complexity.
But agentic RAJ is used in research tools,
advanced assistance,
real-time interactions, etc. Okay,
so when to and fro communications are
going to happen,
obviously you need more architectural.
Complexity plus other complexities as
well, right?
So that is where the evolution of RAJ is
happening,
but basically it is about giving the best
information to the LLM.
So this is how the maturity I was.
I was rewriting this heading multiple
times. Still now I'm not confident.
What should I name this evolution?
Should I just mention it AI engineering
or should there be something else?
I am still not very clear.
But referring to few content,
I saw AI engineering word fits better.
That's how I have given this name. Okay,
but maybe we might change it also.
But as of now,
it started with prompt engineering when
the LLM was introduced.
when ChatGPT came in. Basically,
we focused only on how we can talk better.
So the engineering part was only confined
to the prompts.
So everyone who wanted to use the LLM
effectively started rephrasing that to a
better logic.
They came up,
I think Microsoft even released a format
for it in between. So all that worked.
Then, then drag.
Kayam.
Rag plus prompt engineering wanted to
expand that and it was named as context
engineering. So it is not only prompts,
whatever the model knows in terms of
context relevance,
curating the right data, all that.
And when...
The RAJ started being more agentic in
nature when it wanted to have iterations,
plus it wanted not just to have documents,
but also call external tools.
When MCP and other things came in,
there was so much of control we have to
do because the agent started talking to
the external systems for information.
etc.
So that is where the entire harness
engineering.
is about.
So harness is engineering about how are
we going to govern or build a layer about
the model to all whatever it is talking
so that we can.
give it the complete autonomy,
but we are also safe because the output
also guardrails.
Everything is something we have to
engineer.
So that is where harness engineering is
about.
And after I was deciding that this is
what should go into the course,
in the last few months,
in the next two months,
there are two new terms.
So we have loop engineering and graph
engineering, which has come in.
OK, I'm not getting into the detail,
but I thought I will give you at least
some.
importance of it.
So loop engineering is what they done.
I think loop engineering.
I think again,
Andridge was the one who talked about it.
So, loop engineering basically is a.
About how this entire workflow which I'm
talking about the harness.
plus everything agents iteratively act
upon, review outputs, check the results,
and go back and refine their own next
step, right?
That agent loop is what loop engineering
is about.
Right, so when I say loop engineering,
it is,
it doesn't really or it doesn't leave out
harness engineering.
Loop engineering orchestrates what the
agent does when it starts,
how it evaluate results.
and when the task is finished.
So that agent, where all it works, right?
Harness is where the agent runs,
the tools it access to,
how errors are logged in,
how the data is processed,
how are we going to read the output of
the...
LLM,
are we going to accept it as such or are
we having a refinement guardrail to check
whether it is valid? And it is also,
harness is also going to decide whether
the loop is going to stop or run because
our guardrail,
so remember the sensors we had in loop
engineering.
they are going to decide whether the loop
is going to stop or whether the loop has
to refine and run back. Right?
So that is basically what they claim as
loop engineering.
So a harness is what a single agent lives
inside. A loop
is what decides when to spin the agent,
what to do it,
and how many times it is going to run.
So that's one way of understanding loop.
And then there is graph.
Engineering,
so you the entire system is built as a
knowledge graph,
so the the relationship between the nodes
that do the work are the and then the
edges that interaction between the nodes,
right? So, a node can be an LLM.
It can be a simple API deterministic
function. It can be a.
other routing information, so all that.
So that is very new graph engineering.
So, that's how it is evolving, actually,
OK?
So the structured workflow.
To put it in very simple terms,
this is say this is my agent, okay?
This agent finishes this work and this
agent takes up the next work.
Say I'm doing a spec,
say there is a design agent,
then there is a coding agent,
and then there is a testing agent.
This is what it is.
Okay, so I can rerun this.
Before it goes to the next step.
OK, so this is what loop is about.
But graphs is about is not a linear flow
anymore.
I can have workflows, OK?
Say, I will have a design.
And then I will have a coding,
I will have a testing.
I will go to this agent, testing agent,
if I'm going to do a test-driven
development or certain conditions.
I might go to this or this based on a
workflow and certain parameters, right?
I might, the agent path.
is going to be decided on workflows and
there are going to be certain actions
which I'm going to take based on certain
responses out of that agent coming in.
So real production systems,
they need to retry.
Sometimes what this agent would not
finish his call or there might not be an
output coming out of an LLM.
or they have to pause for a human input.
So there are many places where we cannot
have a linear flow at all.
It has to go beyond the linear flow.
And that is where the graph engineering
comes into picture.
So it is writing steps
That's not linear in nature,
but there can be more complex workflows.
Within that.
So that is where they are exploring the
term graph engineering.
But I'm just giving you as an additional
information.
So this is how it's like totally new.
So basically this line I liked very much,
which I took from, there is one,
AI engineering.
In the reference section, I think.
A genuine.
I think they were talking.
I'll add that. Okay,
so the center of gravity in AI keeps
drifting away from the model and each
shift picked up a new name. Okay,
this is what the AI engineering blog says.
So initially it started with prompt,
then context.
Hardness and loop.
and graph.
So where you are concentrating,
that is where you are working.
So if you are concentrating on the state
and handle errors,
you are working on harness engineering,
or if you are concentrating on all this
is going to coexist and no one is going
to replace the other.
But where you are concentrating,
you can call yourself as a
a prompt engineer or a context engineer
or a harness engineer and I can be,
the wonderful thing is I can be a prompt
engineer today morning and I can be a
context engineer today afternoon.
That's the best thing about this.
Right, so this is the diagram which.
they have given and not in full agreement
with the diagram.
I don't think graph or multi-agent
networks are completely a loop is a
subset of that.
Maybe we might have a few different
directions also. But still,
the inner part seems to be a little
logical and we can agree to it.
And considering the evolution,
I think this diagram is much more useful.
So prompt is only on the context, sorry,
only on the core request,
and comes context, then the harness,
and then the repeating systems plus the
multi-agent.
So that's how you should see the
evolution.
Of the AI.
OK, but.
The most important things we will focus
on as because this course is AI Augmented
SDLC, right?
So though we understand the entire AI
part, our focus will be on the spec,
harness and the loop layer, right?
How AI is augmented.
in translating our initial requirement to
a deployable product.
That is where our focus will be.
So the spec layer, the harness layer,
and the loop,
how many times the loop is going to run,
or what is the convergence point.
That is where our focus is.
Will be on in this particular course and
autonomy wise.
We are.
We will be somewhere here or somewhere
here today,
but our goal is to reach an autonomous
system in the future.
Or we might not reach also, I don't know,
for some places we might never reach the
autonomous stage at all. Right?
We might be a human in the loop where
every...
agent requires PR action.
We might for some instances or some
scenarios,
we might be human on the loop where you
just look at,
you don't do anything specifically,
but you still are aware of what is
happening.
And then autonomous is you don't have to
look at it.
So the idea or the goal is to go to an
autonomous phase,
but sometimes we might decide for this
scenario,
I'm never going to go to an autonomous
stage at all. So that is completely fine.
But this is how the gates of autonomy
will also be defined.
So our focus on this course will work
around these.
Aspects only. OK,
so we will start with the spec driven
development.
And we will get into each of the phases
of SDLC,
how to build the harness around it when
we are using the AI.
And we will work on the autonomy part.
So that would be a focus for the course
as well.
Can we relate autonomous to something
like steady state for an application? No,
it's not to the application,
it is for the developer.
Whether the agent is going to...
Ask the user or the human for something
before it goes to the next step.
So,
if there is a I have changed something on
my application, say I have a chat bot,
I have added a few new rules to the chat
bot as a separate branch in gate,
and I want to merge that branch to the
production main branch. I raise a.
pull request and what do I do there?
Whether I'm waiting for my manager or a
human to approve,
that is human in the loop.
Like a manual review,
there is a manager who sits and sees the
PR details and then agrees to go ahead.
That is human in the loop. Okay.
Human on the loop is the new feature is
added automatically to the main branch.
The agent notifies the human on the loop
if there is something which goes beyond
certain.
parameters. So for example,
say the manager says that you can add
that always my availability or the
response accuracy should be 99.99%.
If it goes below that,
then it is a problem.
So the agent continuously,
agent will automatically merge the.
branch or it will not a pull request will
be satisfied.
It will not wait for a human review,
but the monitor will still be human.
So they have options to go back like
administrators and stop it if something
goes beyond certain parameters.
So I say that accuracy or relevance goes
about.
below 99%,
you raise an alert and immediately stop
or you will have a failback path.
Then it stops.
So that's human on the loop.
Autonomous is it will only do the it will
only monitor now it goes below 98 means
it will automatically roll back that PR
back that particular feature back and it
will it will only automatically do the
corrections or it might it might
automatically revisit the entire cycle
and see what is wrong.
So that is the autonomous thing.
Okay,
so what level of autonomy we are going to
give it to the agent? Well,
it depends on the scenario, the product.
There are many things. I mean,
our goal is to achieve autonomous,
but I am not today,
I cannot say that everything will become
autonomous in the future. No,
it is not possible with the high risk
systems we are running today.
So, and with what we have today,
tomorrow it might become.
Possible, also. OK,
so going to the few closing remarks on
this.
Topics,
which is the other slide which I have
planned for today.
So, what is this?
I actually explained to someone's
question today.
I think what I explained today,
like transfer when SESHA asked about
transfer learning and does RAJ get into
the model itself?
That is where the difference lies.
when we define line we are talking about,
right? So prompt engineering stops.
without getting into the model.
But whereas fine tuning is you go and
update the model parameters or model
weights, etc.
So you're getting into the model.
So a software engineer's work will stop
or will treat the model as a black box.
Whereas the AI and ML engineers.
will get in, I mean,
I'm just using the terms for your clarity,
but in reality,
many of you might be doing different
things, okay?
But fine tuning is more getting into the
model where that's the responsibility of
the person who manages the model or
maintains the model and how they want to
improve the model.
So, the difference between prompt,
context,
and harnesses prompt talks only about the
task for question.
The context talks about the reference
material and the harness talks about all
the other aspects which the model will
refer to to answer that question. Right?
So the target audience is the LLM.
Here we are giving the target audience as
the AI engineer because it is they have
to work. The LLM is only updating models,
parameters, context, etc.
But this involves other tools,
other AI data they will be using more
plus.
other connections they will be bringing
in.
etc.
So here you will work majorly with
natural language or it lies in the user
input or application logic.
Here database will play a major role in
context and harness you can put it in the
CI/CD pipeline, local testing.
path or entire development cycle itself,
harness will come in.
Even harness is going to come in in the
design, architecture design also, right?
So security, so sorry, circuit breaker.
Have you heard of circuit breaker, anyone?
You will read it about,
you learn about it in one of the courses,
scalable services, if you are off.
thing for that elective.
Anyone has heard about circuit breakers?
in microservices.
Yes, some of you might have heard.
So that's a pattern. How do you retry?
So number of retries goes beyond a
certain numbers. We cannot, we will fail.
So circuit breaker is a pattern which
will help us to limit the number of
retries. It is like our circuit break.
which we have in our homes, right?
If the electricity voltage exceeds a
certain limit,
we'll break it with the fuse, right?
So similar to that,
circuit breakers are there in
microservices to control the retries.
And it goes to a closed state and then it
becomes to an open state.
state after a safe amount of reliability
is brought back in the microservices.
It prevents cascading failures,
one microservice failure leading to
cascading microservices failure.
So we will be,
we have to put a pattern like that for AI
calls also.
So that's where harness engineering will
do the work. So we call AI,
it's not giving a relevant output or
sometimes the output might itself not be
coming.
Either the AI is not available or there
is some outage or some problem I heard
day before yesterday or 4th.
Third,
there was some outage in many of the AIs
for all, even Anthropic, Cloud, Open API,
everywhere, Open AI,
many had outages is what I heard.
So such things are happening.
The token limit is reached or there can
be many things.
But how do you prevent that failure to
cascade to other layers?
Or how do you have a failback, sorry,
fallback path?
So there is a lot of software
architecture which you have to plan
around that.
So that is what harness engineering will
concentrate, right?
So scaling up the LLM to real-time
systems is what harness will work.
Context is to prevent hallucination,
give the right information,
and optimizedly use the token limit, etc.
And prompt is only for the context.
So nothing is going to replace anything.
But this is how it is evolving.
The work we do is getting evolved.
So AI engineering versus ML engineering.
I'm not sure whether AI engineering
itself is a word which is right.
It is still a software system built on
with the use of AI.
That is what I think that.
But that is a term which is used and I
often refer to that.
A book AI engineering because it is very
good for a beginner, etc.
So I stick to this term AI engineering.
But when I say AI engineering,
it is the software product,
the software system we are building with
the AI, etc.
So when you started with ML engineers
initially,
They spent a lot of amount of thing on
the data.
because they spend,
data is the base in which they are going
to get the output out of it, right?
So they spend a lot of time on the data
and building the product comes last,
right?
Some ML engineers were not even involved
in the product discussions at all.
like software engineers.
They were often treated as two different
disjoint processes only.
LLM or model was treated separate.
They were not involved in project
discussions or they were not involved in
design of a product, et cetera.
So that was.
ML, basically.
But with AI engineering,
you are doing a lot more than just using
the ML. Of course,
you are focusing on the data to be sent
to the LM,
but you are focusing on a different data.
You are focusing on the context data.
Whereas this ML engineer focused on the
data in which the model was trained on.
Right, so that is where the same data,
model, and product.
These are the three things which are
there,
but the view with which you look at.
Is different,
so ML engineers looked from a data point
of view.
They fed that they first prepared the
data, fed that to the model,
and once the model was capable,
depending on its capability,
it was used in a suitable product,
but here we are focusing on the product.
What we want to build is the first thing,
and then we invest in the data and the
model.
Whatever,
and we choose the model which fits our
product.
Hey.
So that is the change, AI engineering,
or what we are focusing more on.
So then can you ask, well,
will this ML engineer become obsolete or
it will stop? No,
they will still be doing their work
because this model to come here.
As a good model,
this work will continue progressing.
Here we will continue progressing the
different points.
So that is how it is going to coexist.
Right?
So the data centricity was the major
thing in initial ML and AI engineers,
but now AI engineer is more of how do you
put that model?
How do you build the harness around it?
And then how do you bring it out as a
product for everyone to be?
Used.
So,
it is not going to initially model slide
that there inside the Python notebooks
only, right? They were there,
they were producing outputs,
and there was one API call that's all.
You build the model and it was being used
by everyone, but now it is not like that.
The model.
is there.
The agent is going to talk to many things,
our whole environment.
It's going to talk to other agents also.
So that is where you need more AI
engineering coming in.
So last concept I wanted to discuss is
the MCP. So MCP is...
model context protocol. It was given by,
it's a open source one,
it's given by Anthropic.
It is for how do AI applications connect
to external system. Basically,
the connection was there.
They standardized it in a way so that
everyone can use it instead of reworking,
rebuilding every time.
So I want to connect to different systems.
AI wants to connect to different systems,
like the model wants to connect to a
database or a search engine or a
calculator or a compiler.
or it wants to access some key
information,
it has to connect to the external vault.
So how it is going to talk?
That is the connection a client server
setup is being designed, which is like,
which is called as the MCP.
So there is a client, there is a server.
So an MCP host is your AI application,
which needs the other information.
So say this AI application wants to talk
to different tools.
So all that will have an MCP.
server which provides the content to the
MCP client.
MCP client is the part on the host which
will talk to the servers and it will get
the data for the host.
So it will be like this. This is the host.
Okay,
and there will be how whatever we want to
talk to there will be MCP clients and
there will be MCP servers.
So our API say one API can be.
Here, or there can be a database here.
So this client will talk to the MCP
server and this will get the data and it
will send it.
So this is how and the AI will be using
it.
And the communication which is being used
is JSON RPC2 messages between the client
and the server. So if it's a local system,
standard input output is used.
So wherever you have a local interactions
which you need to do,
which is not over the internet within
your network,
then you can use simpleness message
transmission. That is,
if it is over the internet,
it is a server sent events on top of HTTP
connection. So if you have, you will know,
if you know server sent events,
Server sent events are a client-server
interaction,
which is used predominantly in many
places where the server wants to push the
data.
a lot of live data to the client.
Then first, a HTTP communication, an HTTP,
first of all, works on top of TCP.
So HTTP handshake, TCP handshake happens,
and HTTP connection is established
between the client and the server.
So the HTTP sends a request message,
and then a response comes in.
So always the client has to initiate a
communication to the server,
and the server will send back.
That is what is normal web.
The entire internet works on that fashion
only.
But when the server wants to push updates
directly to the client,
That is where service and events are
coming in. For example,
quick info updates, right? Or live,
take a live stock market applications,
right?
So there is a lot of information which
has to be continuously pushed from the
back end to the front end.
It is not required the front end has to
keep asking every time.
So when such things,
server sent events are best when such
kind of things can happen.
When bi-directional communication has to
be there like a chat application or a
streaming application,
web sockets are there.
But server sent events are unique in
nature where the server keeps pushing the
data to be
front end or to the client I would say.
So server sent events is 1 which is used
here also on top of HTTP.
So first HTTP connection is established
and then the server sent events will be,
the servers will push the data to the
clients. So the communication is.
Pretty similar to how a web application
or a.
internet-based application will work in
MCP if it is outside.
If it is local resources,
then standard input-output communication
itself will be used. So here,
one example I found in the MCP site
itself. So say find the...
The.
prompt is find the latest sales report in
our database and e-mail it to the manager.
If this is the request going to an LLM,
LLM cannot access a database or send
emails on its own.
So it will use one MCP client.
to access the database and another MCP
client to send an e-mail. Okay,
so the tool invocation will, the MCP,
the LLM generates a structure request to
use these tools.
So first it will call the database query
tool and specify the report name.
So the MCP client will then send this
request to the appropriate e-mail, sorry,
database server. And then the MCP server,
once it receives the request,
it will translate into an SQL query,
assuming the data is in an SQL database,
and retrieves the sales report.
It formats the data and sends back to the.
LLM,
which will be received by the client and
processed by the LLM,
and now equipped with the report,
the LLM will.
use the MCP client tool for the e-mail to
send the e-mail.
So the e-mail will go to the MCP server
of the e-mail server and the action will
be conducted.
And then it will give a response saying
that I have found the latest report and
e-mail to your.
So, that's what NCP.
roughly is about. Okay,
it is not similar to API.
It is APIs are when you have a service,
you have a structure in which you can
connect to external services.
So MCP is a layer in which AI talks to
different tools. It's not only.
to microservices or it is not only to
third party services,
it is much more than that.
So you have a client as well as a server.
So it is similar to if you have Java,
RMI and all we had in those early days,
RPC, et cetera.
So something very similar to that is what
MC did.
Basically,
it is an interaction for the LLM to be
outside void, whatever it wants accessed.
So this is the summarization of all these
AI.
So we have 3 layers.
Infrastructure, model, and application.
So model is something we discussed that
we will not get into.
So how the model training happens,
evolution happens, and for instruction.
Application Development is how we are
building an application on top of the
model. So AI interface,
prompt engineering, context, evolution,
evaluation, everything comes here.
And then, where this model is running,
how are you going to run this application
plus model, right?
The compute data management monitoring,
so AI Ops.
will come here.
So, we will be touching upon this layer.
and this layer in few models,
but majorly the top layer.
So I'm done almost 3-4 minutes.
I'll just close this.
So this is the diagram I wanted to talk
about.
So,
we are evolving at multiple dimensions,
as I said earlier, right? So,
when I say we are evolving at multiple
dimensions, the initial, as I said,
the initial life cycle or initial machine
learning was primarily driven by the data
centricity.
right?
It was more focused on what data will go
in, what will come out, etc.
But the critical differences today
between the traditional software systems
and the engineering AI enabled systems is
Not just the...
way in which we can define new existing
techniques as essential start points,
but the difference should be on the
quality attributes which we are measuring.
So today we see security, usability,
privacy among the important architectural
concerns, right?
We are not giving it as an afterthought.
Whatever we design today,
they are being wanted to be usable,
secure, secure, etc. Right here,
this quality attributes will expand to
further explainability, data centricity,
verifiability,
and change propagation for AI-enabled
systems.
Right, so our focus will be more.
The where the change,
we have been building traditional
software systems for a long time.
Now we are building AI enabled systems
with AI augmentation also. So.
The change will be how AI systems are
helping us, how there are a few,
we have seen many risks involved and
problems involved, right?
So how are we going to manage that?
That is what
we have to look at it.
So we are moving towards automating
everything. Second,
we are also working on establishing a
unified process, building clear steps,
collaborations,
and we are investing more in systems,
not just models.
Right,
it is the focus is more on the software
engineering, which wraps around then,
so that we can manage the probabilistic
components,
the non-deterministic components inside.
So, that is where the focus will be about.
OK, so this...
This is 1 good article,
Engineering AI Enabled Systems from the
CCMBAINAI Mellon University.
I've given you the link,
you can read through it in detail.
E.
So, I'll stop here for today.
So whatever I covered till today will be
the syllabus for your upcoming mid sem
examinations.
So we can start revisiting the topics,
preparing it. So next class,
we will start with the spec driven
Development and start with the
requirements.
Uh, face that is one bdb.
Any questions?
Our 19th class is cancelled because of
your exams.
No, no, I have not.
There is no specific question format. OK,
there is.
The questions can be for 8 marks, 5 marks,
6 marks, 2 questions on 8 marks,
so it can be random.
In bits we don't follow a specific
question format.
Okay, so 30 marks is what is the standard.
So it will not go above 30.
So within that 30,
you will have different variations.
As far as this course is concerned,
as I mentioned,
I've given you 2 questions as a sample.
That questions,
we will be building on those.
kind of questions to test your
understanding of all the concepts we
discussed.
There will not be any choice also.
So in a WILP BIDS exam,
there is no choice and there will not be
any MCQ questions on the.
Mid sem and comprehensive exams. OK,
so five questions.
Five to six questions will be the maximum
questions, or sometimes it will be a.
If it's 30 marks,
that can be 4 questions also.
So depending on that, I mean,
it will change within makeup and regular
also,
but roughly it will be 5 to 6 questions.
And some, I mean,
this time talking about this course,
some professors might have different,
they might give you.
three 10 mark questions or some might
give five mark questions,
6 questions also, that depends.
But as far as this course is concerned,
the format,
I have given you 2 sample questions.
So all the questions will be of that
format.
You will be given a scenario or you will
be given a one particular
topic and we will be building on to test
your understanding or your evaluation
skills on that particular topic.
That is how it will be for this
particular AI Augmented course.
And 19th we don't have class because of
the exams. Make up schedule also,
we will not have any class.
So those two weeks we will not have class.
Yeah, during the regular and the makeup,
both weeks we will not have class.
And from after the mid sem,
right after the next week after the mid
sem, that is from October 1st week,
I will start with a tutorial discussion
session. Tutorial session,
or I would not even call it tutorial,
I will say office hours.
What we will do is
We will discuss,
we will have some time in the evening.
So Saturday,
I am thinking that six to seven timeframe
we can keep because we don't have any
other classes on Saturday evening.
If you have any other suggestions also,
let me know,
but I would prefer it being a Saturday.
evening and six to seven.
It will be random conversations,
whatever you want to discuss about the
course. You want to maybe once you have,
we will be starting with the assignment
also from that week.
So anything on inputs on the assignment.
Any other opinions you want to share or?
General discussions about the course,
your queries,
your doubts will be covered in the office
hours. It's just a informal interaction.
I will not have any topic covered in that.
I will not refer to any office hours in
the class, et cetera. Right.
So, and it will not be,
and it is not mandatory for you to attend
office hours. If you have a question,
you can attend this week or you can skip
and you can attend the next week also.
So I will have two to three office hours
starting from October 1st week.
And depending on the need,
we can increase also. But
This is how it can be started.
Like.
batch quiz performance, almost good,
always quiz is something I think I,
you have to tell me how was the quiz,
was it easy or were you able to relate to
all the questions? I mean,
I think almost everyone got above 4.
And mid sem again,
mid sem also will be scenario based
question only for this course.
So, to answer Vinod's question.
SARLA, yeah,
it will be all scenario based for
instance only.
So even I have cut down on the syllabus
to keep it light because many of you are
taking, I got a few emails also.
So I understand the writing exams after
quite a break might be difficult, right?
So that's okay. I mean.
As far as this course is concerned,
you can take it very light.
We are not going to be,
you just concentrate on what,
you go through all our PPTs,
the seven sessions,
it's sufficient enough to you to attempt.
Okay, thank you all.
We'll meet again next week.